trump attackiert nägeln der grund us
bürgerin megan merkel ruft mittwoch
zusammen mit ihrem mann prinz harry die
amerikaner dazu auf bei der us-wahl ihre
stimmen abzugeben
alle vier jahre wird uns gesagt dies ist
die wichtigste wahl unseres lebens aber
diese ist es wirklich den namen trump
hat megan in ihrem aufruf übrigens nicht
erwähnt doch der fühlt sich trotzdem
angegriffen
ich bin kein fan von er ich wünsche
harry viel glück er wird es brauchen ja
da kann man schmunzeln oder man kann es
weil ich gestürzt sein
die schütteln den kopf nicht ganz so
voll das ist nicht mein fall irgendwo
die art gebe haben wir dann recht was
mal was meinen sie also erstmal dass er
das dass er das überhaupt aufnehmen und
finde ich es schon das spricht ja für
sich dass ein amerikanischer präsident
ist sozusagen nötig hat und sich dann da
in sona in so einer lapidaren bemerkung
darüber auszulassen finde ich absolut
unpassend überflüssig und und überrascht
dass jetzt also das gesagt hat also
trump überrascht mich nicht immer also
da das finde ich wenig überraschend weiß
ich aber interessant an dieser
geschichte finde es schon ich meine
prinz harry sagt ja auch ganz deutlich
er dürfte noch nie im leben wählen er
ist eigentlich als roy dazu verpflichtet
sich zurückzuhalten mit politischen
aussagen
und ich finde er lässt sich schon ganz
schön krass da von mängeln vor den
karren
spannend also alles im sweet in suffolk
enden jagen und plötzlich sitzt da in
beverly hills und gibt politische
statements und supported die wenn diese
abgeklemmt licht ja aber wahrscheinlich
nicht also ich finde die aussage als
befremdlich weil nur weil megan royal
geheiratet hat heißt es ja nicht dass
ich nicht sagen kann was sie fühlt und
was sie denkt und das ist was völlig
normal ist in den usa auch viele
prominente die woche keinen bezug haben
zur politik sprechen wahlempfehlungen
aus und die reaktion von trump ist ja
eine reaktion auch auf ihre
wahlempfehlung für beiden und insofern
finde es ganz schwierig zu sagen dass
zum beispiel auch megan sich dazu nicht
äußern sollte weil sie mit harry
verheiratet ist ich glaube das ist ja
ein zeichen dafür haben sich davon
gelöst hat und vor allem ja der titel
abgegeben pflichte abgegeben und so
lange man sich heute können sich also
nicht auch kleinen blatt gut ich würde
mir ehrlich gesagt total wünschen wenn
man in deutschland offen über politik
sprechen würde
da sehen wir ja auch die mccanns zu
seiner politischen ikone hoch ich mag es
ja ich die schauspielerin und hat sich
allerdings für seehunde shelter
eingesetzter hunde in not
also werden sie es sich dass seine
informationen ist deren stimme irgendwie
im politischen amerika bisher vermisst
wurde ist kann sich jeder ein sitz mehr
will ich finde aber dass diese ehe
zunehmend ein bizarres bild ab wirft
also harry morton wie sollte sie sich
dann verhalten seiner meinung auch und
schon in den um sollten deshalb für uns
findet zum beispiel mal in seinem buch
gesagt bzw
lässt sich da natürlich nicht zitieren
sondern großvater und so weiter die
hatten alle privilegien die haben
schlösser die haben bedienstete die
können sich die charity aus der ist im
platz acht in der thronfolge
die können sich wirklich einsetzen in
seinem heimatland das war ja alles
bewusst bevor sie dieses mal geheiratet
hat aber mir kommt es zunehmend zuvor so
herbert nach beverly hills ich kann hier
nicht die ganze zeit im regnerischen
wales um den ring trieb
dass das gerade du das sagst eine so
starke frau mit so einer eigenen gerät
heute übrigens ja einmal und die haben
natürlich haben die bediensteten
natürlich haben wir alle privilegien die
quandt er davon können sie ein lied
singt aber keiner von deutschland ja nun
eindeutig ein bisschen anders natürlich
nervig ist dass ein gewählter präsident
wenn wir jetzt darauf abschied und das
natürlich ein königshaus vor gibt es
natürlich noch ein bisschen anders so
aber ich finde das eher positiv sie ist
amerikanische staatsbürgerin
und ich finde es gut und wie sie schon
sagen es ist auch in
in amerika ist das geliebte kultur dass
menschen die vielleicht auch in der
öffentlichkeit stehen oder auch er
gehört werden einfach auch über ihre
politische einstellung und gesinnung
auch tatsächlich reden
die erwähnt ja auch keinen namen das
muss man ja und dass ihr mann aber sich
da natürlich auf der anderen seite auch
zurückhält ist auch in ordnung also es
kann amerikanischer staatsbürger und ja
der hintergrund aus dem er stammt gebiet
ihm dass das besser ist sich natürlich
zurückzuhalten aber für sich bin ich
doch genau ich finde er hält sich gar
nicht zurück der lässt sich ja vor die
kamera zerren setzt sich auf eine bank
vor dem hintergrund die hunde von mengen
herumlaufen und das einzige was er in
die kamera sagt ist ich durfte ja in
england nie wählen also das wussten ja
sicherlich viele von ihnen sich also
aber sie wussten nun auch viele nicht
richtig dass gar nichts
ich wusste das oriental matti wenn du
umgangen wurde und ich finde dass du die
rolle von megan total unterschätzt also
die ist ein vorbild für viele meiner an
da draußen ist finde ich doch natürlich
ist hier ein vorbild für viele junge
frauen und der weg den sie durchlaufen
hat und auch die entscheidung die sie
getroffen hat indem sie sozusagen auch
dieser form des zusammenlebens den
rücken gekehrt hat auch das ist ein
statement und das finde ich hoch
politisch also die frage ist ja wie
definieren wir politik und ich finde
durchaus dass wir eine politische frau
ist die ihre meinung kundtun wollten die
hat sich wirklich vom königshaus frei
gestrampelt
das muss man auch sie hat sich
emanzipiert hat neben dass man nicht so
lange am rande der haut die musste sie
musste ganz schön viel einstecken und
wann hat man bisher in reits jahr 2020
machten nicht mehr mit
[Musik]